je rappelle qu'en quatre semaines quatre
paquets de sanctions déjà été adopté par
les 27 alors que de nombreuses enseignes
ont décidé de se retirer de russie
certaines ont plus tarder que d'autres
c'est le cas notamment de total energy
christophe dans cette bonjour c'était
l'énergie qui très critiqué pour son
immobilisme a finalement décidé de
renoncer au pétrole russe d'ici la fin
de l'année oui après plusieurs semaines
d'hésitation et de réflexion le groupe
total energy a donc le publié hier soir
un communiqué un communiqué dans lequel
il annonce arrêté tout achat de pétrole
et de produits pétroliers russes et ce
au plus tard d'ici la fin de cette année
2022 le temps de trouver des solutions
alternatives notamment pour qu'on soit
assurée d'avoir du diesel ici dans nos
stations essence en france alors en
réalité total énergie ne quitte pas
totalement la russie puisqu'il va
poursuivre une partie de ses activités
et non pas dans le pétrole mais dans le
gaz en russie le groupe va surtout
chercher du gaz non pas directement
puisque il le rappelle dans son
communiqué il n'opère aucun champ
pétrolier ou gazier en russie mais à
travers des participations dans des
entreprises il y tient par exemple près
de 20% de novatek qui est une entreprise
privée russe ceci dit patrick pouyanné
invité de rtl la radio rtl ici en france
ce matin a affirmé que la russie
était un pays hors la loi dans le couple
dans lequel on ne pouvait plus investir
ce sont ses mots le patron de total
energy ému aux larmes c'est suffisamment
rare pour être souligné vous allez le
voir à rejeter toute complicité de
crimes contre l'humanité comme l'ont
accusé un certain nombre de
personnalités ici en france dont un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle m
est-ce que vous pensez que nous ne
sommes pas des êtres humains et que nous
réfléchissons pas tous les jours vous
avez pas vous avez ainsi là je vais j'ai
la photo de deux personnes ces deux
soldats ukrainiens ce sont deux employés
de total énergie ce sont les deux héros
et mon entreprise aujourd'hui et on vous
accuse de crimes ce n'est pas acceptable
on est des gens responsables
on prend le temps de réfléchir on me
dire tirez vous de russie je lâche tout
jared amener le gaz russe aux européens
qui n'ont besoin alors que les
gouvernements européens nous disent de
continuer puisque ils ne veulent pas le
sanctionner et pourquoi ils veulent pas
à sanctionner parce que sans gaz russe
on arrête une partie de l'économie
européenne et moi je vais décider tout
seul parce que je suis pdg d'un grand
groupe j'arrête le gaz russe j'arrête le
pétrole on cherche des solutions si hier
j'ai annoncé sur le pétrole ckb bornes
total énergie je sais remplacer ce
pétrole et ce diesel le gaz je ne sais
pas le faire
voilà patrick et a fouillé mais qui
répondent notamment aux critiques à
peine voilées du candidat yannick jadot
comme total énergie les entreprises
internationales et françaises en
particulier christophe samson face à un
véritable casse-tête faut-il rester ou
partir de russie mais l'université yale
aux états unis tient le compte des
grands groupes qui ont choisi de
suspendre leurs activités de russie ils
sont un peu plus de 350 dans ce cas là
parmi une dizaine de français on peut
notamment citer la plupart des groupes
de luxe français hermès kering lvmh ou
chanel qui ont fermé leurs magasins mais
aussi à airbus qui suspend ses
livraisons à la compagnie russe aeroflot
un host et dans this c'est-à-dire
peugeot citroën qui arrêtent toute
activité dans le pays voilà ce qu'ils
arrêtent et ceux qui poursuivent comme
meurent nos renault donc le concurrent
français de dust elantis
tout simplement parce que renault est
beaucoup plus implantés en russie comme
l'est et dentistes la russie c'est même
le deuxième marché de renault après la
france il y emploie quarante mille
personnes et à côté de renault peut
inciter d'autres groupes comme auchan
décathlon ou encore leroy merlin gros
merlin dont la position devient très
compliqué il réalise environ 20% de son
chiffre d'affaires en russie il y
emploie 2500 personnes donc c'est
difficile de partir mais le groupe est
également présent en ukraine l'un de ses
magasins a même été a bombardé ce
dimanche
je pensais qu'on allait voir les images
mais les voilà et on voit le ce magasin
qui eux
dont il ne reste plus grand chose
c'était à kiev merci beaucoup christophe
dans ça